puppy what's it asking given that the
tank uh-huh see not so implausible given
that the tank still has 20 liters left
in it when the water flow stops fire be
as a function of time okay so I wasn't
just making it up let's just imagine
that this spot down the bottom here
right this bit but work that refuses to
fall out let's call that 20 liters 23
liters yeah okay so there's a little bit
left so how do I use this to find I want
volume as a function of time volume is a
function of time okay what am I going to
do okay so i can state the the
information in the question i can state
that as well i suppose i could say V of
25 equals 20 that's using function
notation and that's true but it's not V
as a function of time it's v at a
particular moment in time I want
something that teasing it's something
that varies something that changes so
what I'm going to point you to is dr.
this guy over here yes captain right
this is a derivative right if I told you
hey I have some some derivative like
this this derivative it implies a
function that it came from the original
function we call it the primitive right
because it's where you came from so what
would you do to this to find out what
why was you would integrate because you
want to undo this differentiation
process that happened before right so
you differentiate both sides on the left
hand side if you differentiate this
sorry integrate this with respect to X
you're going to get wise and you
integrate this with respect to X you get
X cubed but because this is not an
indefinite enterprise it's not definite
web no boundaries so you don't know
which one of the X cubes it came from is
that whole family of primitives you
remember this so this is going to come
into play when we have a look at this
question I've got an expression for DV
on the team so in order to move towards
an expression for V I need to integrate
this guy right
so I'm going to integrate that whole
function to t minus 50 and I'm doing it
with respect to time okay because this
is a derivative with respect to time
okay let's have a look at this I'm gonna
pull that five out the front and this is
a pretty easy integrator can you tell me
what we're going to head not really good
so as I keep on mentioning the
integration like the actual calculus oh
this is not the hard part okay the hard
part is like what direction am I going
in and what am I going to do with these
functions so now I'm going to put these
two pieces together I actually usually
do not mention this first because I
don't need it until I write down this
line right I can find out what the
constant is because I know a particular
point that the function passes through
that would be like coming to this
question and saying okay sure this
derivative could be a one of these
primitives right but if I know that when
x equals I don't know unless you're
saying goes through the argument right I
can use that to work out which one of
the X cubes it will be well the execute
us zero in this case so I'm going to
pull out exactly the same trick here i'm
going to say i'll go to the next I'm
going to say but when there's a given
time namely at time 25 I know what the
volume is equal to at that point so I'm
going to substep substitute that into my
integrated statement over here so i'm
going to say five times what is 25
square I think it's 625 yeah take away
50 lots of 25 50 25 that's 1250 there is
a constant there this is the right hand
side of evaluating
don't know what that constant is but I
do know what the volume is is 20 okay
you see what I've done so now it's
pretty straightforward to change the
subject and evaluate for see what is
this guy this is 5 times negative 6 25
so if I add 5 lots of 625 both sides
divide not yet I'm just I saw Percy
right that's all I'm doing so there's no
coefficient on that yet because I'm
going to knock on 2003 145 that's really
yeah okay so then I'm going to take this
the whole point of me finding out what
this was or so I could go back and say
what the actual volume is at any given
time so i can say therefore the volume
is and here's my expression okay so hold
on a second what have I done have I
answered the question what was the
question find their volume as a function
of time is that the volume is a function
of time cool nailed it you're always
with all of these questions you go
through an amount of work and then you
think have I answer the question or not
then it is in two parts see the last bit
this is quite easy really the question
was well therefore how much what did you
start with what was the amount of
initially in the tank so initially means
T equals zero right time in faculty room
right now initially d / 0 it's worth
saying that because you can have
negative time in some cases in this case
not because it's like what this is where
it starts it's full initially T equals 0
therefore V equals i'm just going to
substitute in right and you can see
because of what this is i mean i could
actually have factored a tea out which
would demonstrate this whole thing folds
it just becomes 5 times 0 and what you
get left with is that constant i worked
out before
whos console know when you saw ever see
you ready taken in
so the question Jen is asking is do I
have to add 20 right let's think about
what this means right how did I get this
3145 number and the answer is I got it
from thinking about this piece of
information everything about the
integral right so that T equals 25 the
end point and the volume equals 20 is
included it's baked into my calculations
so the sea I counted for that you see in
fact if i subtract it off so I've
already dealt with that does you which I
will later on but in this case look I've
clearly used it so it's not a stealthy
okay so therefore this thing not quite
to scale started off with three and a
bit cheerleaders and then empty down
until this point oh yeah 3 1 45 litres
in fact I should probably conclude
therefore kilo kilo mega 3 and something
three-legged okay so I'm gonna say again
I'm going to add the units in now here
is my conclusion therefore we started
with you mega is a million done sure
just rewind with me for a second
how do we approach this question and
you'll see this pattern again and again
right you will be given a rate and the
rate may be constant but it might be
valuable as in this case this makes
sense doesn't it why is it that the
water slows down as you get closer and
closer to the water what concert didn't
I just say it slowing down so the idea
is I mean there's a lot to do more so
you can think about it and you can think
about what a pressure so all of this
weight here from all this all these many
many thousands of litres of water is
exerting pressure downwards so the more
water there is up here the faster we'll
push out and then it slows down and
suppose that eventually it's not